a Myanmar military court has sentenced
ousted civilian leader aung San tsuchi
to a further seven years in prison she
has been convicted of corruption in what
is the last of a string of criminal
cases against her this leaves her with a
total jail time of 33 years Suchi has
been under house arrest since a military
coup
ousted her democratically elected
government in 2021 her supporters say
the charges are politically motivated
for more let's welcome naiing Myanmar
team leader for the news agency Reuters
so this verdict come as a surprise to
you
hello yes um so this button doesn't come
as a surprise for the media and also for
authorities support us because many
people have been referring to the court
as like kangaroo courts and then they
claim that these partakes are confident
with the truth and evidences so on this
edition of seven years in addition to
the 2016 that has already been sent us
that's a really surprised to the people
hmm what's been the response from tsuchi
and her supporters
so um just like I previously mentioned
like uh supporters said that they gone
down this kind of arbitrary detections
and they call for the release of their
sensiti and also other political
prisoners and then they know they
explained that this costs are stage and
then this course have been her behind
closed doors at the room in Libya prison
and then so they said these are and just
and they don't accept this kind these
all these rulings and asansuji hasap has
addressed these charges as assault
when one sits on the outside of this
watching what's been going on with
tsuchi over the years you have to ask
what is the current situation like in
Miramar today for the political
opposition
so um
was the whole Revolution
for an election in distance in this
upcoming year 2013 by August that's
their current timeline and then many
political parties especially assassin's
parties were called this election and I
mean most of the most of the top key
politicians were already arrested or
imprisoned by the owner so they are not
going to participate this anyhow and for
the rest of the Revolution the fighters
are still continued across the country
in the middle part of the country or
also under borderline the revolution has
been continuing and also like in City
area like Yangon Mandalay flash mobs are
happening from time to time where also
continue the arbitrary address
there is a shun naing with Reuters many
many thanks
for more I am joined Now by Phil
Robertson deputy director Asia division
Human Rights Watch in Bangkok Thailand
Phil what does this verdict tell us
about the military junta's plans for
Suchi and other opposition figures
well for Suchi they're locking the door
and throwing away the key they want to
keep her in prison and I expected we
will not see her again she is considered
to be the preeminent political threat to
the military coup government she's
someone who has won two national
elections by Landslide most recently in
November 2020 which was the government
that was overthrown in this coup and I
think that they are putting her away for
good uh they are going to lock her away
in a prison in Napier the remote
administrative capital of the country
and keep her away from her supporters
and from her lawyers and from others and
uh you know she will become a hostage a
hostage for democracy uh in Myanmar
in any response from her or her
supporters
well she is being kept in incommunicado
uh and even her lawyers are not allowed
to speak to the media or anyone else
about her case uh or face criminal
sanction uh her supporters I think will
be making plans to somehow demonstrate
and and uh object to what has happened
to her uh but of course they face a
violent Crackdown uh if they do so and
so it's quite clear that the military is
trying to keep her away from her
supporters to try to keep news about her
out of uh any sort of discussion within
the country
right now is there a viable political
opposition in Myanmar
well there's certainly certainly I mean
what's going to
hand-going efforts by both the the
non-violent uh CDM movement and also the
people's Defense Forces which are
violently contesting uh against the
military will continue uh they will just
continue without her and without the
national league for democracy or her
party which I think is being
increasingly sidelined as well
um the situation is one where the the
push and pull the sort of tug of war
between the military and the people will
continue and this is uh not changed as a
result of her arrest but it will
certainly add fuel to the fire of her
supporters who are against the military
government that you know their Champion
has been put away uh for 33 years which
at her age at age 77 is a life sentence
that is uh Phil Robertson in Bangkok
many many thanks Phil